all right so we're going to talk about what to
do if you have calcification in your arteries
i've done other videos on this there's a really
good test that you can do to determine if you
do have calcium in your arteries in fact
it's one of the best predictors of mortality
so i'll put a link down below for more information
on that if you are not familiar with that test but
this video is on a protocol that i would recommend
to help undo the calcification in your arteries of
course the best thing is to prevent it but what
do you do if you actually have calcium buildup in
the arteries all the things that i'm going to talk
about are not meant to replace your medical care
just do your own research i put some links down
below for every single thing i'm going to talk
about the first natural compound is allicin
which happens to be the phytonutrient in garlic
some real interesting research on the association
of allicin and decrease artery calcification
in animals so if you have a pet with a
calcified coronary artery start feeding them
garlic immediately number two butyrate now what is
butyrate butyrate is a compound that your microbes
in your gut make when you feed the microbes fiber
and i'm going to recommend vegetable fiber but it
is actually a type of fat it's a small chain fatty
acid that's produced in your gut from microbes
from vegetable fiber and that too is associated
with a decreased risk of artery disease now
number three lycopene this is a phytonutrient
in tomatoes it's in a lot of other vegetables
and there's some real interesting data of showing
how lycopene can decrease the thickness of the
wall of your arteries and also decrease the
stiffness and this is why sometimes you'll see
some crazy claims that oh now you can have ketchup
and it's going to decrease your risk for heart
disease because ketchup has lycopene of course we
know that's not going to happen now also if you
add olive oil when you're cooking it can greatly
increase the amount of lycopene up to 82 percent
and that is because like other phytonutrients
lycopene is a fat soluble compound which means
it requires bile and adding more oil into the
diet can greatly enhance the absorption all right
number four omega-3 fatty acids the sabian fish
oils definitely cod liver oil which i recommend
more than fish oils i mean we know that omega-3
is good for so many things but its main action
in relationship to your arteries is the decrease
in inflammation but it can also increase the risk
of getting a clot now on the flip side the omega 6
fatty acids increase stiffness of the arteries and
it can increase the clotting factor and when
i'm talking about omega-6 i'm talking about
the soy oil the corn oil the canola the cotton
seed now there is one type of omega-6 that is
very friendly to your arteries and it doesn't
increase inflammation and that would be called gla
or gamma linolenic acid this would be like borage
oil black currant seed oil evening primrose oil
so GLA can help decrease inflammation it can help
decrease thickness in your arteries it can also
decrease the plaque formation in your arteries i
put some links down below very very interesting
all right number six vitamin k2 you probably knew
this was coming i would recommend getting the mk-7
version and i would consume about 300 micrograms
every single day now what does vitamin k2
do it activates a certain protein that inhibits
calcium from forming in the arteries so that's a
very very important one number seven tocotrienols
tocotrienols is one form of the vitamin e complex
and it's about 50 times stronger than tocopherols
and it can greatly decrease inflammation in your
arteries it can decrease something called
c-reactive protein which is an inflammatory
compound by 40 and lastly and most importantly
is doing whatever you can to decrease and reverse
insulin resistance there's a direct relationship
between having insulin resistance and having
calcification in your arteries and so a lot
of these other remedies are not going to work
unless you also correct insulin resistance how
if you're new to my channel i put the link down
below you need to do healthy keto and definitely
intermittent fasting for a period of time to
start making changes but it's my opinion that the
combination of addressing insulin resistance with
tocotrienols with k2 with allicin and omega-3
are probably the most important things you can do
and these other compounds are are also good but
i think using them more as a secondary approach
thanks so much for watching i'll see you in the
next video before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto and you want
to know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the US hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help